speaking of uh
mutilation
and
humiliation yep
yeah we filmed something for a project
yeah yeah
um and we really went through our paces
yeah we face some fears so we can't we
can't say what it was that we shot but
it's probably never gonna see the light
of day yeah i don't think anyone's ever
gonna see this footage i don't think
maybe maybe they will maybe you'll see
it one day but
um
yeah so i think that you know the the
tone of the day was to face some fears
yep all right um and the particular
fears we dealt with were animal related
so first you know before we get into you
know the hero moment and and and i know
what you're thinking and the answer is
yes we did drive a tesla into the camera
yeah yeah and we
killed lobsters with our bearings yeah
yeah
no how funny would that have been if
they brought one out and they were like
you need to
cook this lobster like easy
they're like no no no don't don't
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
why did you do
that oh man
so
we
you know first i got to talk about this
snake
can i talk about the snake yeah
okay you know i'll just redact names and
you know
but
so this guy brings out uh like what
looks like
a a gatorade container at a football
game and now you know i was joking
imagine
that [ __ ] was just at the super bowl and
someone goes to undo the top and they're
like yo they go pour it on the coach and
a five
foot six rattlesnake
dumps out of it
yeah and just
cause that's what came out of this jar
it was a five foot six rattlesnake this
thing was a beast yeah like scary scary
snake the dude handling it was probably
like what 6'4 that dude was huge
big boy big boy and he had help and he
when we're when we're
when we're saying this to you right now
when we say snake handler what do you
think he looks like what do you think he
looks like
you'd say he's australian yeah and you'd
say he's probably wearing like green
cargos yeah and like a green like cargo
shirt and a bandanna around his neck
it's exactly what he was wearing yep i
mean could not be more cliche yeah but
so legendary yes dude was awesome um and
we found out later that he had nicknames
or he was very good at improving
nicknames for his animals um
he referred to he's like he's a i got a
five foot six rattlesnake in there um
and his name is [ __ ] for good reason
and i was like can you imagine we get
killed today by something named [ __ ]
we find out later that he just calls
this snake a number of names so it kind
of felt like a you know felt cheated but
the snake comes out of the of the
gatorade tub
and this dude is having a time
trying to get it to [ __ ] chill out
because the whole point was for him to
grab its head and and drain the venom so
cody and i are standing there which by
the way is called milking a snake
milking a snake
and which we are very familiar with yeah
we're good at it now
i've always been good at it
i just learned
my snake only recently started
milking
you just learned how to calm
yeah i'm 15.
sick dude congrats man your life is
about to start yeah i just came
man
what an opportunity like the first time
you not to just i just came yeah it's
like
you know you for the first time you've
never done it i just came i remember the
first time i ever came yeah i thought i
was like i thought i had like i broke
something yeah
don't didn't didn't you like it felt
wrong
when nah it just felt like oh [ __ ] that
shouldn't have happened
but it felt so good i gotta do it again
yeah well no i like i
what did i do to my dick there's [ __ ]
coming out of it when i learned not [ __ ]
but you know [ __ ]
yeah i see that like you did break it
yeah yeah something's broken a whole
turd comes out of your pee hole damn
damn
saturdays are back
oh they're about to be back
oh yeah yeah yeah the snake so keep
going with the snake milking
so this big ass dude has you know and by
the way they the tools they use for the
snake it's like partially very legit you
know they got these giant dentist tools
like to [ __ ] pin the snake down and
then they use uh
the most professional thing i've ever
seen which is a broom yeah
and
uh his assistant is leaning on the snake
with all of his body weight like i can
see the front of the this dude's like
business shoes planted into the dirt
like he's trying to pin it down and then
the big guy
he's using
some steel like hook and he's just
saying oh oh i'm gonna kill it if i put
any more force i'm gonna kill it yeah
the whole vibe on set was like hey do
you guys do you do this yeah do you guys
know what the [ __ ] you're doing because
they're both like sweating and
struggling the australian guy's like
crocky
ah she's a real mean one
all right little bugger
hold this hardest thing hold his thing
it's really intense
and he the snake got so pissed that it
actually bit into itself
uh
trying to attack them i felt kind of bad
for it yeah and meanwhile its tail is
going
and it's like
so when all of us are like
this is sick
he pins it down he goes to grab its head
and then it it like it nipped so he
pulled his hand back he's like ah [ __ ]
i'm like dude that it almost got you
right here she can't yeah you can't
that's what he said yeah
hey you [ __ ] can't
so then he he pins it he grabs its head
and then he's trying to put it under his
arm to like
get it in position and i very distinctly
remember him saying
i can only hold his head for so long
because my hands get tired
and i'm thinking about him because he's
not he's not a young fellow he's towards
the end of his career and the whole time
i'm getting pissed internally like you
know no shade to the guy but i'm like
why at the end of your career are you
fighting the scariest snake you've ever
fought bro like don't do that with us do
that on your personal time yeah so as
he's trying to get under his arm
the thing is like coiling and he can't
get control and he's like barking at his
assistant to be like unravel it unravel
it
wrong way
and now the dude is and the snake is
just doing barrel rolls yeah straight up
just like just yeah flipping over and
the guy's like that that part stressed
me out the most because that that looked
like he had zero control over yeah
yeah he's trying to like wrestle it
while holding its mouth open and his
fangs are just out like this thing's
ready to kill
and his assistant is sweating bullets
his eyes are so big and he's like doing
these ballerina moves to get it to
also i don't think you saw this but
right when he grabbed his head some
liquid sprayed
on his assistant's face no yes and i
don't know what it was but his assistant
immediately was like
like wiping his face
the venom from this thing would kill
like an elephant yeah you know the guy
was describing it to us it's like if you
get any any part of this even the
smallest amount in your bloodstream then
like
in your leg for example your leg would
swell up to like three times its size
and they'd have to like cut it open to
relieve the pressure like a hot dog yeah
he said
it would uh he said he's seen people get
bit and their hams their hands their
hammies their yams turn into hamstrings
yeah yeah
like the
he said it
you'll balloon up like a ham and you
know
on time we were like well why don't they
make that for penises yet just a little
slow penis plumper yeah yeah i would do
that voluntarily yeah
well what if it was just like a pre-sex
like
it's ballooned up yeah
made from real rattlesnake venom yeah
damn
we should sell that it would actually be
kind of a gas station like horny pill
yeah
yeah rat rattle pump yeah
it comes with a little shaker in the
package that that's just for fun yeah
maybe yeah
it was rattle time uh-oh oh my god you
want to charm my snake
so anyway
these [ __ ] finally get this thing
pinned down and at that point i'm like
is he is his hand just gonna give out
and this guy dies
but he he milks the snake
i i held its tail it was pretty gross
and um we look at the venom yeah the
venom was i don't know it was like a
quarter shot of alcohol and he's like
yeah this could kill six people
i was like god damn so why do you why do
you do this yeah literally it was also
funny because everything else we had
done that day was sort of like dares and
then that part was just kind of random
yeah we nobody knew what the purpose was
yeah it was just like look at how cool
this is and we were like this is not
cool it's kind of scary yeah
yeah we just like willingly
engaged almost dying yeah like that
thing could have just killed all of us
yeah if it felt like it yeah
i could have owned that farm yeah
you